hello everybody and welcome to another
python tutorial this video in the next
couple videos we'll be covering
the else statement typically people only
use the else
statement with the if statement but this
isn't totally necessary
you can also use it with the for wow and
even the try
statements so and actually the accept
statement but we'll get to that
so first why would you want to use it
with
something like the four
like a for loop so let's say you wanted
to run through a python list
looking for a variable in that list and
if you found that variable you would
want to do
something if not found you would also
maybe want to do something so
in my case whenever like i back test
stocks let's say for example
we're going to go through a list of
parameters and if those parameters are
met
then we would say okay we've got to buy
let's say otherwise we don't have a buy
continue
something like that right so let's say
that's the case so how would we actually
do that normally well
first we're going to need an example
list so let's say example
list equals and this list is going to
equal 1
2 3 4 and 5. now
next thing we're going to do is we're
going to say y equals 3 for now so we're
just going to kind of define this
fake variable and then we're right what
we have to say is like what we're going
to do
is we're going to run through this
entire example list and we're going to
see if y
is if the condition of y is is present
within the example list
as we can see in already yes it is
but this is meant to just be an example
so the way that you know
you would probably do this is you would
have something like this like matched
equals and the default is going to be of
course false
and then he would probably write a loop
like 4x
in example list
if x equals y then
print matched and then we'll go ahead
and say like what we matched because not
only do we want to know
like if that was in the list because
really if you just want to know
is this variable in this list uh that's
very simple
you can you just have it if y in example
list
right but what if you need to know like
what that variable actually is
right that's in that list because
typically y would be dynamic so
anyway continuing on um so we actually
we want to know
not only did it match but what did it
match so the next thing that we do now
is
we need to say matched equals true
but if there was no match we're still
not covered
right so the next thing we want to say
is if match equals
false we'll just print no
match found right so let's save that and
run that and make sure that works so it
did
indeed match 3. now if we change this to
7 for example save that and run that
it's going to say
no match found but there is a better
more pythonic way to do something like
this and that's going to be
for else so instead of all this uh i
guess what i'll do is i'll just comment
this out
so we can count the lines in a minute
it's gonna be one less line to use for
else but it's also going to
be a bit smarter thing to do so now
um oh and in fact we need to
do this okay so now we're gonna rename
this to three again
and now let's do the four else so we're
gonna say instead for x in
example list if x
equals y print
uh and we want to print out the same
thing as before so matched
and then what was matched and then we
have to throw in a
break now let me get through this and
i'll explain
why we must have that break there so
then we add in
else print uh no
match found done so
the way you can think of a for else
statement see most people envision the
else statement as like
if the prior statement returns like a
false
you know that's kind of how they think
of it so they expect that
the else will just be called if nothing
actually executes in the for loop or
something
and the problem here is that the for
loop doesn't really inherently break
when something happens it doesn't add
return of false and you could have
multiple
truths in theory right so it doesn't
quite work like that so the way that you
should really envision this
is like this is all one big loop
so when you break you're breaking past
the else right because the else is part
of that loop
right so that's kind of the way to
think about it and like later on you'll
see when we have like accept else for
example except else works much more in
the way that you might think it does or
it should
anyway let's say that we'll run it and
again we have the same result it matched
3
and if we changed y to 7 for example
no match is found now at the end of the
day
this whole thing is one two three four
five six lines and this was one two
three four
five six seven lines so not a huge
difference but this is a completely
unnecessary variable there's also
problems that could arise with the depth
like
defining it like this this is also more
a little bit more efficient because as
soon as it's found
it's going to break for you so that's
kind of nice but obviously if you wanted
to find maybe multiple matches
you wouldn't make it all the way through
before it actually broke so you'd have
to kind of consider
all these things but at the end of the
day uh this can also be used for
a variety of other things not just you
know like what i was saying so
anyways hopefully you guys learned
something new if you have any questions
feel free to put
them in the comments below otherwise
uh stay tuned we have a few more else um
statements to throw in
uh so stay tuned for those and otherwise
as always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support and the subscriptions
and until
the next video